what I want to do in this video is make
sure we really understand what's going
on when we call our recursive Fibonacci
function so I'm going to assume that
someone calls the function with an
argument so they call Fibonacci of and
they give past 5 as an argument I don't
want to pick too large of a number for
the argument because otherwise I'll be
explaining this forever so let's try
Fibonacci 5 so in this situation within
the context of this function the
parameter n right here is going to be is
going to be equal to 5 so in that first
pass the parameter n is going to be
equal to 5 and the way we wrote it we
said if n is less than 2 of return n
well 5 is definitely not less than 2 so
we're going to go to the else part of
the if clause or the else clause and we
say return Fibonacci of n minus 1 plus
Fibonacci of n minus 2 so when I call
this it's essentially going to be
reduced if you want to think of it that
way or simplified or I guess it would
return this thing is going to be the
same thing as Fibonacci Fibonacci of
remember n was 5 so n minus 1 is 4 plus
Fibonacci plus Fibonacci Fibonacci of n
minus 2 well in this when we ran the
function here n was 5 so 5 minus 2 is 3
well these are just more function calls
so now we're gonna go again but now n is
not 5 it's now 4 & 3 so let's try this
out so over here over here n is equal to
4 and is equal to 4 so once again 4 is
not less than 2 so we don't you we don't
do this part we go to the else so we're
going to return Fibonacci of 4 minus 1
which is 3 so this is going to simplify
2 or Fibonacci or break down I should
say Fibonacci of 4 minus 1 which is 3
plus Fibonacci of 4 minus 2 which is
Fibonacci Fibonacci of Fibonacci of 2 so
this right over here will we'll
essentially return this and this over
here on the right Fibonacci of 3
Fibonacci of 3 let me draw
let me make it cuz gonna get jumbled up
soon so this this returns this the stuff
in magenta and then the stuff I
underlined in green will return n is now
three three is not less than two so you
go here Fibonacci of 3 minus 1 which is
Fibonacci of 3 minus 1 which is
Fibonacci Fibonacci Fibonacci 3 minus 1
of 2 and plus Fibonacci plus Fibonacci
plus Fibonacci of 3 minus 2 which is
Fibonacci of 1 and then we're gonna go
over here and we're gonna have to
calculate each of these things because
these are just more calls to Fibonacci
and Fibonacci of 3 so you can see how
this is getting pretty involved right
now in fact I'm gonna start writing fib
but short for Fibonacci so I don't run
out of real estate Fibonacci of 3 when
you call it n 3 is not less than 2
you're gonna go here that route that
reduces to Fibonacci of 3 minus 2 so
that is Fibonacci that I'll just write
fib short for Fibonacci Fibonacci of 2
plus Fibonacci plus Fibonacci of 3 minus
2 plus Fibonacci of 1 so it reduces to
that or breaks down into that and then
over here Fibonacci of 2 Fibonacci of 2
2 is not less than 2 so we're going to
have to return Fibonacci of 2 minus 1 so
that's Fibonacci of 1 plus Fibonacci of
2 minus 2 so plus Fibonacci plus
Fibonacci of 0 so it breaks down into
those two calls to Fibonacci and then
over here Fibonacci of 2 same thing we
made a call to Fibonacci of 2 that's
going to break down just like this call
to Fibonacci of 2 did it will break down
to a call of Fibonacci of 1 plus
Fibonacci of 0 so we get that and then
we have Fibonacci of 1 this is
interesting because when n is equal to 1
now all of a sudden this Clause up here
becomes relevant because now n is less
than 2 it says return n so this right
here is going to simplify this term
right over here is going to simplify to
1 it's going to evaluate to 1
then we look at all of these over here
Fibonacci of 2 we know that Fibonacci of
2 evaluates to Fibonacci of 1 plus
Fibonacci of 0 so let me write that over
here so this over here is Fibonacci of 1
plus Fibonacci of 0 fib is short for
Fibonacci and then we know Fibonacci of
1 1 is less than 2 and is 1 here so
we're going to just return and so this
is this is going to return 1 Fibonacci
of 1 just returns one Fibonacci of 0
well 0 is less than 2 return 0 Fibonacci
of 0 returns 0 Fibonacci of 1 we've seen
it it returns one Fibonacci of 0 returns
0 and then Fibonacci of 1 returns one
Fibonacci of 0 returns 0 so the whole
time that the interpreter is processing
this recursive function call this
recursive function call right over here
it kind of has to remember all of the
previous how it got there because once
it eventually gets down to the base
cases gets down to N equals 1 or 0 and
actually gets a numeric response and
then has to build up to its previous
response so Fibonacci of 2 right over
here it's 1 plus 0 so Fibonacci of 2 is
going to simplify is going to simplify
to 1 Fibonacci this Fibonacci of 3
what's going to be Fibonacci of 2 plus
Fibonacci of 1 those had simplified to 1
so this is going to be 1 plus 1 this is
going to be 2 we go over here Fibonacci
of 2 Fibonacci 1 plus Fibonacci 0 1 plus
0 this is going to be 1 Fibonacci of 2 1
plus 0 this is going to be 1 Fibonacci
of 1 well that's just 1 and now we go up
to this level we're kind of going
reaching it back so that we get to the
original function call and I'm not going
to go into the details of what how does
the interpreter actually doing that this
this is actually a fascinating
discussion but I'll just think about how
to how do we think about it what's
happening in this recursive function
call and why is it working why is it
giving us the right answer and then we
go over here Fibonacci of 4 well
Fibonacci of 4 is the fourth Fibonacci
term is the sum of the third and the
second Fibonacci term which we've
already figured out those are 2 and 1
you take their sum you get three the
third Fibonacci term by the definition
of the Fibonacci sequence is the sum of
the
first and the second terms the first and
the second terms those are each one one
plus one is two the fifth term the fifth
Fibonacci number the fifth term in the
Fibonacci sequence is the sum of the
fourth and the third terms those are
three and two three plus two is five so
this thing right over here is going to
evaluate to five so hopefully that
clarifies a little bit of what how this
recursive program is actually working
what's neat about it is it wouldn't work
if you didn't go down if you didn't
define the base cases the Fibonacci of 1
or Fibonacci of 0 then it would just
keep calling itself forever and never
get anywhere it what the key with
recursion is it can call itself as long
as every time you call itself it's
making its way down to the base cases so
at some point if it keeps calling itself
keep calling it keeps calling yourself
eventually it's going to able to build
back those calls as or it's able to get
to the base case and then reconstruct
what the original value is from that and
so that's why this working every call to
Fibonacci is a simpler version I have a
lower end and eventually my ends are
going to get to the base case which will
of which will actually give me which
will actually give me actual actual
values that I can then reconstruct for
our original call so hopefully that
helps a little bit recursion can be
confusing but at the same time it's kind
of elegant and beautiful in its own way